today we are gonna fight we gonna stand
strong for what we believe in each other
last month the corridors of power in
Washington opened up to the world's
oldest profession 40 sex workers met
with 30 members of Congress to push back
against the fight online sex trafficking
Act
why would professional lawmakers meet
with professional lawbreakers reason
tagged along to find out why so what
we're doing right now is super exciting
because as far as we know there has
never been a sex worker Lobby day on the
hill but there is today we're going to
be going to our representatives talking
with them a lot of them aren't super
familiar with sex worker rights
particularly in the wake of cesta and
how cesta has impacted us cesta is a
bill that passed recently that heavily
restricts and criminalizes advertising
for sex work on the internet to stop
enabling sex traffickers act or a cesta
would allow sex trafficking victims to
have their day in court by eliminating
federal liability protections for
technology providers that knowingly
knowingly facilitates online sex
trafficking today when the House votes
on FASTA we will be sending a clear
message businesses that sell human
beings online can no longer do so with
impunity
Fausta stands for fighting online sex
trafficking Act it is a law that
purports to fight minors being forced
into sex with it and it purports to do
it by increasing liability for online
intermediaries the bill also provides
increased criminal liability and thus
deters websites and individuals from
selling human beings online websites
will no longer be able to turn a blind
eye or actively conceal this horrific
practice without facing very real
consequences the federal government says
if you're an online platform you
generally are not liable
for what goes on on your by users on
your site Fausta and cesta before that
are the first steps toward enforcing
more liability allegedly to go after sex
traffickers we're really fooling around
in an odd way that you don't expect
we're fooling around with one of the
legal foundations of the internet that's
been really so successful particularly
with social media craigslist and reddit
have already shuttered sections of their
website exciting FASTA liability
concerns Facebook and other large
technology companies have backed the
legislation while a trade group
representing startups has opposed it
thank you very much crucial legislation
to combat online sex trafficking and
bring criminals to justice signing the
bill was very much in character for
President Trump it's a bill in which it
appeals to people's gut instincts about
things it doesn't ask questions about
are we going about this in the right way
what are the cost what are the common
you know all of those issues populist
don't ask those questions the only
surprising thing is he didn't support it
more strongly and I think that's
probably because he himself has legal
and the political issues connected to
various kinds of sexual issues let's say
today Carl Ferrer the CEO of
backpage.com
the man behind what authorities are
calling the world's top online brothel
facing criminal charges for the very
first time the purpose of government is
not to make people into better people
morally if government's role is to
enforce a vajura tea or a minorities
view you're going to be coercing people
who are pursuing their idea of what the
good life is
[Music]
to even discuss sex work it's something
that we weren't sure what the response
would be for that sure and that is the
problem that we're trying to overcome
here right now is the the lack of
communication because we've found that
most people don't even know what
Boston's esto Mar / were and that they
were very effectively manipulated
essentially into believing that it was
truly an anti-trafficking law when in
reality it is hurting survivors of
trafficking and it's really hurting sex
workers sex workers often advertised on
the Internet as a way to screen clients
and this is a huge help in keeping
people safe if you don't have the
ability to check on someone's criminal
record for example before you meet up
with them you don't know if they could
be violent or not and because FASTA
limits in a lot of ways the ways I am
able to advertise and run my business it
makes it more dangerous for me
Department of Justice has sent over a
letter very last minute kind of speaking
to the if I called ad hoc but the
fast-moving nature of the bill that they
obviously weren't even consulted before
it's brought to the floor yeah and you
know even DOJ was saying that they
questioned highly the constitutionality
we live in a system where the process is
supposed to be deliberative it's
supposed to be fairly slow you're
supposed to have committee work it's
supposed to be informed and detailed the
original law had many problems and there
was a lot of informed criticism of it
and Congress on the house side was
responding but then suddenly was pulled
out of committee on the house side
brought to the fore for a vote and
passed an ensign
President Trump once it got out of that
and got defined as are you for or
against coercively forcing children to
engage in sex you know that was the
definition and no one was over 30 more
congressional representatives would open
their doors to Jenks and other sex
worker activists that day and by the end
of the month the Electronic Frontier
Foundation joined Human Rights Watch and
the Woodhull Freedom Foundation in a
lawsuit challenging FASTA in federal
court I'm not saying I'm happy with
Washington DC I'm not saying I'm happy
with the politician I'm glad they did
the thing that they are supposed to do
which is represent us so you can't bring
down the whole system overnight
we can't decriminalize sex work
overnight either but as we continue to
have dialogue with our representatives
perhaps we can shift it a little bit
closer to the kind of government that we
say we have
[Music]